[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
Hello, everyone.
My name's Wojtek.
I'm a developer advocate working
with the Android Studio Team,
and today I want to tell you
a little bit about performance
tooling that we are releasing
soon with the new Android
Studio version, 3.0.
And why performance tooling?
Because I think we all
know, perf matters, right?
That's not something
I have to convince
you developers that it's true.
So let me keep this intro short.
But I just want to
tell you a little bit
how I understand app performance
and what it means to me.
So imagine that performance is
actually a measure of your app
quality, right?
Now, the user will
download your app
and install it because
they want to use
features, the features that
you implemented, the benefits
that the app gives them.
You design a great
UI because you
want the user to be able to
access information quickly,
and you want them to feel good
about just using your app.
Think about the other part
of the user experience.
What if they actually
want to use it,
but if they're
frustrated because when
they keep the app open the
battery drains very fast?
What if just having
the app installed
means that their phone dies
twice as fast as before?
The user cares about the
responsiveness of the device,
about a smooth UI, about
how fast the app installs,
how much space it
takes up on the device.
And all these things
ultimately will
make your user
happy or frustrated,
because they're using your app.
And ultimately,
it's what they will
feel about your
app and what rating
they will give you
on the Play Store.
So what can we do about
this as developers?
I see it as a two way process.
You have to be proactive
and you have to be reactive.
Now, what does it really mean?
So even before you start
working on your app,
you have to plan
for performance.
When developing,
before the release,
you have to keep
measuring and profiling.
Like, what does it mean
that your app is performing?
How can you know if it's
performing up to the standards?
You have to actually
plan for some numbers.
Just do some benchmarking,
look at your competitors' app,
see how fast they work,
how fast they start.
Just write down some
figures and plan for this.
Then when you release,
maybe you will not
nail it on the first
time, but at least you
will have something to strive
for and to try and fix it.
And then be reactive.
This whole process doesn't
end when you actually release
your app and you're done.
No.
It's all about monitoring
and reacting to any problems
that arise.
And you have to have tools
to be able to debug and fix
these things.
So today I'm going
to talk a little bit
about the new Android Profiler,
available in Android Studio
3.0, which is currently in beta.
And this is a tool that replaces
the old Android monitor tab.
You can see here, when you
launch your app on a device
or emulator, you open
the Android Profiler
tab at the bottom.
And you see this view.
This is what we call
the unified timeline.
You can see three charts--
the CPU, the memory,
and the network charts.
But what's really cool about
this view is here at the top
you can see an additional track
with some important app events
that are happening, such
as input events, rotations,
and activity state.
And looking at these
things gives you
more context to actually analyze
the data that you see below.
So imagine here I'm touching
the screen, interacting
with my app, and
I can immediately
see on the CPU chart that
my app is doing something.
It's actually processing
the input events.
Then when I rotate, you can see
that activities are changing.
The activity is
getting destroyed,
a new one is being created, and
something is happening there
with the memory in CPU.
Now when you click on
any of these tracks,
you can actually go
to a detailed view.
And let's start with
the CPU profiler first.
So the UI is a little
bit complicated.
I know it can be a little bit
hard to see from the back.
So let me just walk you
through the main points here.
So here on the left, you
can see the thread list.
These are all threads
that were active
when you were profiling your
app using the CPU profiler.
Here on the top, you can, again,
see a chart of CPU activity.
You can see spikes whenever
there was something happening
in the app, such as
activity creation, swipes,
list scrolling, and so on.
And finally, you can
see thread states.
So you can actually see which
of the threads were active
and their associated state,
such as if they were sleeping,
active, waiting
for I/O, and so on.
Now you can glance at this
and already figure out
that something's happening.
But the nice thing
is, you can also
start method tracing from
here using this button.
Method tracing is basically
recording all the method calls
in your app so you can
analyze them better
and figure out which
methods are taking up
the most time in your app.
Now there's two ways
you can do this.
This dropdown next to
the Record button--
you can select the sampled
or instrumented trace.
The difference is,
well, pretty small.
I mean, they both essentially
do the same thing,
except the sampled one
has a smaller overhead.
But it can miss some very
short-lived method sometimes,
because it samples
every x milliseconds
to check which methods were run.
Whereas, if you choose
instrumented traces,
they will record every
method enter and exit,
but the overhead will be bigger.
So what happens when I press
the Start Method Tracing button?
I interact with my app,
I swipe on the screen,
I do some transitions, I
rotate my phone, I press Stop.
And when Android Studio
stops processing the trace,
you can see this view.
So here at the bottom,
we see a code chart
from the selected
slice of time that you
can see on the timeline.
So here I selected the moment
when I was rotating my phone
and the activity is getting
destroyed and recreated.
So imagine this is
an image gallery app.
And I notice that when
I'm looking at an image
and I rotate my
phone, the activity
takes an unusually long time
to actually restart and show me
the image again.
So I want to see
what's happening there.
So I can actually
zoom in this chart,
because I want to see the
exact calls that were made.
Or I can just drag and drop
and select on the timeline
a smaller slice of that
recording, of that trace.
And here at the bottom
on the code chart,
you can see all
Android framework
methods highlighted in yellow.
All methods from
my code that were
called in this trace in green,
and some other standard library
methods in blue.
So again, for those who
can't see the small text
on the screen, here I can see
the whole onCreate method.
And actually the
width of the chart
represent for how long
the respective methods
were running.
And the first thing
that runs in my onCreate
is lay out inflation.
It takes some time.
That's OK.
I can't do anything about it.
But then I notice that there
are two very long method
calls in my code,
which actually create
disk caches for my images.
And first of all, I can see that
I'm actually hitting the disk.
I'm creating caches, I'm reading
disk from my main thread.
I can see that
because I'm actually
analyzing the main thread,
which is highlighted
at the top on the thread list.
I can also see that all this
takes almost twice the time it
takes to initialize my layout.
So I should probably not
be doing that in onCreate.
And that's it.
In 10 seconds, I was able
to quickly glance and see
what's happening
my onCreate method
and why it's taking so long.
So I really recommend to
try this for all the places
where you need to finish
something quickly,
if you're doing any calls
in layouts, in the computing
layouts, in custom
drawing for your views,
anyplace, basically, that may be
impacted by doing a lot of work
on the CPU.
Please check it out.
There's always also other
ways you can look at the data.
So the code chart is obviously
a very visual way to analyze it.
But you can also open
the top down view
and see all the calls
from the thread root,
from the main method, all the
way down to individual methods
that were called in your
app, and also see some data,
like relative times
of how long they ran.
And there's another
way of looking at it.
In the bottom up view,
that's the second tab,
I can actually sort
all the methods
that were called by
how long they ran.
And I can immediately see the
method I was telling you about,
the create disk caches method,
is very high on the list.
I can immediately see that
that method is actually
making my onCreate slow.
And then if I expand the
nodes in the tree view,
I can actually see
where it was called.
So instead of going
from the thread route
to the individual methods, I'm
going the other way around,
starting with the
method I'm interested in
and finding out which place
in my code I was calling it.
OK, so let's move on
to the memory profiler.
So here again, same situation.
I'm rotating my screen.
Something's being
recomputed, recreated,
and my memory goes up.
You can immediately see
that from the chart.
You can also see
some more events.
So you can see when GCE
events were happening.
If you see too many of
these small trashcan
icons in a short amount of
time, and if the memory is going
up and down, up and
down, that means
you might be
thrashing the memory.
You might be creating
objects and destroying
them, which again, might impact
the performance of your app.
Just for debugging, if you need
to force a garbage collection
event, you can do
that from here.
But the coolest part
about this memory view,
about this memory analyzer, is--
by the way, this is all live.
I know I'm presenting
this on screenshots,
but this is all going live
when you run your app.
And at any given moment, when
you see something happening,
something interesting
happening in your app,
you can drag and drop on the
timeline and select slice
of time without any
prerecording, pressing
any buttons first, and
see all the allocations
and deallocations that
happened at that time.
So here you can see some
input events on the top.
This is a situation
where I was just
scrolling a long list of
items, again, of images.
And you can see, just like
I said, memory goes up,
memory goes down.
There's a lot of garbage
collection events.
And for some reason, my
scrolling is very janky.
I can see that the app is
loading something and just
thrashing memory.
So I'm inspecting this
place for possible culprits.
And at the bottom, you can
see a list of all the classes
that were either
allocated or deallocated
within that time slice.
But the really helpful
views are actually
hidden under a dropdown, so
you can arrange this data
in different ways.
So here I selected
Arrange by Call Stack.
And I can actually
find the place
in my list adapter, the
getView method, which,
if you remember when
you have a long list,
the adapter recycles
views, and that
has to provide them
whenever a new view has
to be shown on the screen
when you scroll it.
So I found the getView method
that does exactly that.
And I can see all
the allocations
that I'm making there.
And it turns out
there's actually a lot.
You can see the
number of allocations.
You can see the memory size
that is being allocated.
Another way of looking at it
is you can arrange by package.
So let's say I'm not
interested by any third party
libraries that are doing
allocations right now.
I'm not interested in
the system classes.
I'm only interested in classes
from my code, so something
that I wrote that
is being allocated.
So that's another
way to look at it.
So let's go back to
analyzing the getView method.
So when you actually
select a class,
you can see on the
right a new view opens,
and you can see all
instances or all objects
of that class that were actually
allocated and deallocated.
Even more, when you select
any of these objects,
you get a call stack.
So you can see exactly where
that object was allocated.
So you can track down
these rogue allocations
and try and fix
it somehow, maybe
move it to some warm up
before or some shared cache.
Another thing you can do
with the memory analyzer
is that you can
analyze heap dumps.
So whenever you want to examine
some state in your app--
let's say you were
using your app.
You're were just using it
as a normal user would,
and something's wrong.
You got the app under
some weird state.
Maybe some view is not
showing, maybe some image
is not loading,
and you just want
to figure out what's
going on, or you just
want to figure out, where is
all that memory coming from,
all these memory allocations?
What objects actually
exist in my app?
So just press this
button, wait a bit,
and then you get a
similar view as before,
except now you have
a snapshot of memory
from your app at the time
when you pressed the button.
So again, you have
a list of classes.
You can click on it and
you get a list of instances
of objects of those classes.
And here the view looks
slightly different.
So for every instance,
you can actually
analyze all the fields,
all the values that
were held there, just
as if you were debugging
the app in Android Studio.
So this is nice for figuring
out the state of the object.
But if you have
another problem, if you
know you have a memory
leak and, for example,
you see an object that
shouldn't really be there--
let's say it's some
activity that you actually
stopped interacting
with a long time ago,
and it should really be
garbage collected by now
but it's still
there in the list.
You can use the
bottom view here,
the References view,
to figure out who's
holding references to my view.
Who is preventing it from
being garbage collected?
And here, by
expanding the nodes,
you can find a
chain of references,
usually to the window
object or to some route view
or whichever object is
being held by the system
because it's active in your app.
And then it's holding
onto these objects
that you would
really like to, well,
enable them to be
garbage collected.
So a great way of
analyzing memory leaks.
And finally, the last
profiler, network profiler.
So this view is
quite interesting,
because you can use
it for two purposes--
well, analyzing network
requests, obviously.
But the other one is it actually
shows you the radio power
state, and you can figure out
some battery problems that
might be created by your app.
So the radio state can be
shown in three states, really.
It's either Wi-Fi, low powered
radio or high powered radio.
And the way the GSM
radio on your devices
works, when it doesn't have
to do any transmissions,
when you're not downloading
or uploading data,
it can go to a low powered
state to save battery life.
As soon as you want
to make a request,
if your app has to
hit the network,
the radio has to be powered up.
That have already
takes up some battery.
Then you make your request, and
then it stays up for some time,
just in case you want
to request some more
data from the network.
And that can be wasteful,
but you can actually
minimize that impact by
batching your request.
And if you look here, if you
look at your network profiler,
after using your
app for a while,
after interacting
with it, you can
see if your requests were,
well, batched in one place.
You woke up the radio once,
did all your downloading,
and then the radio can go
to a low powered state,
or if you are waking the radio
up every minute, every 30
seconds, and then figure
out how to fix it.
Obviously, the network
profiler is not only
about the radio state
and the battery,
it's all about networks.
So at the bottom, you see
the data transfer graph,
you see how much data was sent,
when the requests were made.
And again, like on the
previous profilers,
you can select a chunk
of time and then see
all the HTTP and HTTPS requests
that were made in that time.
It's a little bit
similar to DevTools
that you know from
Chrome, for example.
You see content-type, you
can see a timeline with time
that every request took.
But even more, if you
click on any of these,
you can see the actual payload.
So if it was an image,
like a JPEG or a PNG,
if it was text,
such as JSON or XML,
you can see the actual data that
was downloaded into your app
through that request.
You can obviously also
see HTTP headers--
very useful for debugging any
problems with server APIs.
And finally, you can see
the call stack showing you
where the call was
made in your code.
So that pretty useful.
A few comments.
The profilers work
great on Android Oreo.
You don't have to
literally do anything.
They should just work
with any debuggable APK.
They also work on
lower API versions.
However, remember
on Nougat and below,
you have to build and deploy
your app from Android Studio
to use all the functions
of the Android profilers.
And you have to remember to
enable advanced profiling.
If you don't have it
enabled, don't worry.
The profiler will
show you a prompt
and it will literally
be one click fix.
And there are some
small differences
in how profilers work.
So for example, in
Nougat and below,
to track memory
allocations, you actually
have to press a Record button,
just like in the CPU chart.
Other than that, most functions
should be available for you.
And there's one more new
thing in Android Studio 3.0.
If there are any, for example,
game developers out there,
or people who use
alternative ways to build
your APKs such as different
IDEs or different tool chains,
and you would like to use all
these new Android profiler
goodness, or just use Android
Studio to debug your app,
there's now a new project
type in Android Studio
to debug external APKs.
You can select this
profile or debug option
from the Android Studio
launcher, the first screen
that you see.
Select your APK, and it will
be like a dummy project will
be created for you
with the APK attached,
with the Java code
decompiled to Smali.
And you can even see the
APK contents open in the APK
analyzer for you.
So you can do that to
load an external APK.
You can even attach Java sources
and attach native libraries
with debug symbols.
That lets you do step by
step debugging in your code.
And yeah, if you've
always wanted
to use Android Studio for APKs
built with something else,
do try it out.
So I mentioned APK analyzer.
That was the window
on the right.
It's not new in
any Android Studio.
However, Android Studio 3.0
brings some pretty notable
improvements.
The way you launch it is
you can select Analyze APK
from the Build menu.
Just one word of advice.
If you build your APKs during
development using Instant Run,
using the Run button
in Android Studio,
don't open these using
the APK analyzer.
They don't contain all
the classes and resources
that you want to actually
look at and analyze.
Instead, press the Build
APK or Generate Sign APK.
Wait until the APK
builds, and you'll
get a nice notification
APK is ready.
You can either locate it on
disk or open it in the analyzer.
So when you press Analyze,
APK Analyzer launches.
You can see-- let me just give
you a short walk through if you
haven't used it before.
But it's been in Android
Studio for some time.
And you can see the
contents of the APK,
all the files, some basic
info such as the file
size of the APK,
file sizes inside,
the download size, because
Play Store compresses
the APK for delivery to devices,
and then you can actually
dig into the classes--
they're in your
classes DEX files--
and resources.
What we've added
Android Studio 3.0,
you can actually now see a third
column showing you the sizes
of the DEX code in your APKs.
So you can actually see
the size of a package,
the size of a class,
and even the size
that a method adds to
your class as DEX files.
So it's pretty good
for figuring out where
all that space is going to.
But there is a new thing I
wanted to announce today.
And just last night, we
updated the Android SDK tools
in the Canary Channel,
and we are now
offering the APK analyzer
as a command line
tool for using your CI
servers and build servers.
[APPLAUSE]
So this was a
longstanding request.
I'm happy we are finally
releasing to you in preview.
I'm hoping you'll try it out.
It does most of the things and
even more than the APK analyzer
in Android Studio.
Syntax is pretty basic.
It has commands that let you
inspect things in the manifest,
in the APK, in the deck size,
and even print out resources
from the resource table.
It will be great for generating
reports on your build service.
It will be great for
comparing two APK
versions to see where
you've regressed
when it comes to APK size.
With some script-fu,
you can even
figure out very, very specific
changes in your APK, such
as you take two APKs, you
list all the packages inside,
all the classes, and you
notice that between these two
versions, some developer in your
project added two new classes
and they take up x amount
of space in those APKs.
So these are only some ideas
on how you can use them.
I'm curious to hear your
feedback on this tool.
So please come to see me after
the session and let's talk.
And the last thing I wanted
to mention at this session
is Android Vitals.
So this is a place in the
Google Play Console that
lets you track and see some
common problems with your apps
that are happening on user's
devices, such as ANR rate.
ANR is Application
Not Responding.
This basically happens whenever
you use network or storage
from the main thread.
You can see the crash rate.
You can figure out things
like slow rendering
or frozen frames,
which usually means
you're doing something wrong
with the CPU or memory, as I
showed you you can
analyze before.
And finally, stuck wait
locks and excessive wake ups,
which have an impact on
the user's battery life.
We also offer all
this information
on developers.android.com.
So every section
has a dedicated page
that explains all the
tools and debug methods
that you can use to
figure out these things
and fix them in your apps.
So I really encourage you to
look it up in the Play Store,
in the Play Console,
and start working on it.
So thank you very much.
I'll be here on Level 3 in the
Android Office Hours Booth.
If you want to talk about
the new profilers on the APK
analyzer, please
come talk to me,
and I'm curious to
hear what you think.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]